bonsoir il est 18h si vous nous
rejoignez en direct pour cette nouvelle
édition du Journal de la rédaction et
dans l'actualité de ce mercredi 29
octobre Journée mondiale de lutte contre
l'accident vasculaire cérébral l'AVC
information et conseils dispensé à
l'hôpital du Chesnay chaque année 155000
personnes sont touchées 62000 en décède
40 ans après les accords de paix entre
la France et le Vietnam une exposition
propose jusqu'au 14 novembre de
découvrir des costumes traditionnels des
minorités ethniques de ce pays mais
aussi des bijoux des objets
usuels des photographies et des films
s'est à Versailles et Versailles
toujours avec la sortie d'un guide
artistique et historique Alexandre Maral
conservateur en chef du Château propose
9 promenades pour découvrir ou
redécouvrir la cité royale il est à
l'invité de cette édition et pour
débuter un anniversaire gourmand les 20
ans du Salon du Chocolat à Paris Porte
de Versailles à partir d'aujourd'hui et
jusqu'au 2 novembre 20 000 mètres carrés
avec des expositions des conférences des
dégustations bien sûr à l'incontournable
défilé de robe en chocolat répondra en
point d'orgue de la manifestation les
Yvelinois seront présents et pour
découvrir leurs actualités rendez-vous
demain jeudi soir sur tvfils pour fil
Eco reportage autour de ces artisans
dans le magazine hebdomadaire proposé
par la rédaction
c'est aujourd'hui que ce terminé le
procès d'un ancien policier accusé de
viol l'effet remontré à 2012 il se
serait produit dans une cellule de
dégrisement à Mantes-la-Jolie on
retrouve à Versailles Anthony rechez
Elodie moine à la cour d'assise l'effet
remonte au 16 mai 2012 ce soir là la
police conduite au commissariat de
Mantes-la-Jolie une femme
ivre voulant tout casser à son domicile
mais lors de sa période en cellule de
dégrisement la victime et le brigadier
chargé de la surveiller ont un rapport
sexuel accusé de viol ces textes
policiers de 40 ans révoqué de la police
nationale depuis les faits plaid le
malentendu sexuel je voulais dire
qu'elle se souvient de rien se souvient
uniquement des actes qui accusent mon
client par contre les propos qu'elle a
tenu avec les policiers qui l'ont amené
en véhicule au terme desquels elle aura
parlé de son amour de l'uniforme de son
amour de la salsa ou elle a plaisanter
ou certains des policiers le terme
d'aggy sur ça elles s'en souvient pas
que mon client est un monstre ça elle
s'en souvient
après trois jours d'audience la victime
une femme d'origine espagnole de 46 ans
est apparu à la barre ce matin la voix
tremblotante jugée fragile
psychologiquement mais crédible par les
enquêteurs cette femme a déclaré sa vie
détruite depuis plus de 2 ans et demi
cette fameuse nuit du 16 mai 2012 pour
son avocate le verdict de ce procès peut
avoir valeur de symbole la déclaration
de culpabilité pour moi s'impose dans ce
contexte là sinon c'est la porte ouverte
à tous toutes les dérives si on commence
à tolérer ce genre de comportement ça
veut dire qu'il peut se passer n'importe
quoi dans un commissariat de police dans
le quartier de Mantes-la-Jolie la
population a déjà une mauvaise image de
sa police elle est souvent dans une
situation de défiance à l'égard des
forces de l'ordre ça a été ébruitée
cette affaire il y a eu des articles
dans la presse locale et les gens se
méfient beaucoup et hésiteront je pense
à l'avenir à les déposer plainte si
jamais il est acquitté l'avocat général
a requis 10 ans de prison contre ses
textes policiers le verdict est attendu
dans les prochaines heures
dans l'actualité également de ce 29
octobre la grève des postiers sur Vélizy
les secteur de Versailles bucu Viroflay
ou encore Le Chesnay était concerné à
l'appel de la CGT mobilisation a eu lieu
pour dénoncer une détérioration des
conditions de travail des agents des
perturbations ont été enregistrées dans
la distribution et dans la collecte du
courrier les accidents vasculaires
cérébraux à l'origine de 62000 décès
chaque année en France leur nombre pour
les 20 à 64 ans a augmenté même de 25%
en 20 ans entre 1990 et 2010 journée de
mobilisation aujourd'hui de prévention
comme à l'hôpital du Chesnay Patrick
Jacques de dixmu des Catherine zulato
pour ce reportage
un accident vasculaire cérébral c'est la
survenue d'un déficit brutal
neurologique où il existe une lésion
vasculaire dont 80% des cas il s'agit
d'un infarctus cérébral soit un caillot
dans une artère l'importance en cas
d'AVC c'est de réagir très rapidement
dans les 4h30 après la survenue des
premiers symptômes les signes les plus
caractéristiques en général ça survient
d'abord brutalement et c'est souvent
indolore ce qui dit souvent on ne fait
pas consulter les gens ça peut être des
troubles de l'élocution par exemple un
patient il ne peut plus sortir un mot ou
un mot pour un autre ou un jargon
incompréhensible après il peut y avoir
des symptômes moteurs alors on peut
remarquer une déviation de la bouche par
exemple ou on tient on lâche la
fourchette tout simplement et ça ça
revient ou bien ça reste et puis on peut
avoir par exemple déficit de tout un
côté droit ou gauche dès l'apparition
des symptômes ne pas hésiter à composer
le 15 impossible de prévenir un AVC il y
a 150 causes différentes parmi les
facteurs de risque le tabac l'alcool
l'hypertension ou encore le diabète max
sera mis a été victime de deux accidents
vasculaires cérébraux le premier en
février 2012 et le second en décembre
2013 le premier il m'a surpris même je
savais pas que c'était un AVC
le second je m'en suis pas rendu compte
puisque je venais d'être opéré et le
lendemain de mon opération j'ai fait la
vaisselle aujourd'hui après de nombreux
efforts de rééducation Max a pu
récupérer son bras gauche et poursuivre
la sculpture c'est grâce à la sculpture
un peu que j'ai repris maîtrise ma main
droite ça prouve quand même aux gens qui
viennent voir on peut faire des choses
malgré un AVC c'est un message d'espoir
c'est tout et c'est ça pour les
orthophonistes que ce soit pour son
paralysés etc il faut travailler
jusqu'au point l'an passé 700 cas d'AVC
ont été traités au centre hospitalier de
Versailles un nombre en évolution
constante
et à l'occasion de cette journée de
prévention des AVC nous sommes allés
vous rencontrer dans la rue à 50 ans en
Yvelines pour vous demander si vous
connaissiez les premiers symptômes et
surtout comment réagir oui je crois
qu'il y a
l'histoire du langage qu'on n'est pas
franchement je connais pas je sais que
les gens
gens qui
me paralysent
le père de la vue
des sensations d'un côté soit dans les
jambes soit dans les bras difficultés de
langage peut-être
il y a un petit test on fait appeler les
secours déjà je
pense sinon il y a un petit test est-ce
que vous pouvez lever le bras paralysie
faciale
perte de la parole je crois et
c'est tout nous en parlions hier le
premier bailleur d'Île de France loivois
est dans une situation inédite Yveline
Val d'Oise et Essonne doivent composer
le conseil d'administration de l'office
HLM de 50000 logements mais seul le
dernier département l'Essonne donc est
encore représenté et le locataire
s'inquiète reportage
le premier bailleur d'Île-de-France
fonctionne depuis maintenant deux ans
avec un conseil d'administration réduit
en cause la démission des élus des
conseils généraux des Yvelines et du
Val-d'Oise seuls les seules à maintenu
sa présence à l'époque il souhaitait
tirer la sonnette d'alarme et alerter
sur la gestion et la situation
financière de ce bailleur mais depuis la
situation n'a pas évolué ils n'ont pas
été remplacés une situation que déplore
les locataires les conseils généraux
d'origine et du 95 garantissent plus les
emprunts donc ça fait que ça ça a bloqué
des projets que ça n'a même certains
projets abandonnés comme un ville
prolétait comme une certaine rapidation
mis du temps à se mettre en place donc
maintenant pierrevady nous dit qu'il y a
d'autres mécanismes financiers certes
mais il est présent du conseil général
et avant avant la mise en place d'autres
mécanismes c'est plutôt à lui en tant
que président à garantir l'empreinte du
deuxième bailleur de France les
administrateurs ont encore présents se
disent fragilisés un constat repris par
le nouveau président de lors de sa
première conférence de presse en
septembre dernier oui moi j'ai été
frappé et heurté de voir des élus du
Conseil Général du 78 et du Conseil
général du Val d'Oise qui depuis deux
ans refuse de sier au conseil
d'administration de l'opivoie ils ont
leur place mais depuis 2 ans ils n'ont
pas désigné leur représentance à thèse
d'une forme de désinvolture pour le
président du conseil général la solution
réside dans la départementalisation une
fausse bonne idée selon les
administrateurs ce changement de gestion
accentuerait les écarts en termes de
logement entre les départements
très très inquiet au sein de l'opivoie
et ça veut dire quoi vis-à-vis de la
solidarité en Île-de-France c'est pour
ça que la religion est un est un projet
structurant la départementalisation a
pas de sens à l'échelle des des
économies qu'on pourrait faire la loi
alur permettrait à l'opivoie d'être
régionalisé d'ici 2016 des négociations
seraient actuellement en cours en
Île-de-France
l'opivoire regroupe 50 000 logements
dont 16000 dans les Yvelines
place à l'invité de ce 29 octobre et
bonsoir Alexandre Maral vous êtes
conservateur en chef du château de
Versailles on va parler de votre ouvrage
de cet ouvrage Versailles côté ville
côté jardin 9 promenades d'art et
d'histoire on est sur un ouvrage qui
invite à la détente à flâner un petit
peu et puis surtout à se rendre compte
que Versailles ce n'est pas uniquement
le château qu'il faut prendre le la
ville comme un ensemble avec son château
c'est tout à fait ça c'est pas seulement
le château c'est pas seulement le musée
c'est un territoire c'est une ville
c'est un domaine et c'est Versailles
dans cette dimension dans ces dimensions
multiples que bien finalement j'invite
les visiteurs à se promener à
redécouvrir ces lieux il y a en
comprendre là non seulement la
complexité mais la cohérence parce que
tout se tient
tout a été voulu conçu par Louis XIV et
c'est encore sa pensée son schéma
directeur qui régit cet ensemble
extrêmement vaste et il y a même la
dernière des promenades là il faut
vraiment des chaussures de marche parce
que on parcourt le domaine parce que
vous qui officiez justement pour le pour
le château de Versailles on se rend
compte que les touristes d'oscillos loin
qu'ils viennent se concentre uniquement
sur sur ce château c'est difficile de
les faire sortir du château c'était il y
a ceux qui viennent de loin on peut de
temps à passer à Versailles alors
évidemment il privilégie les endroits
les plus forts comme la galerie des
glaces ou la chambre du roi mais c'est
vrai que si on a un peu plus de temps et
ça vaut vraiment la peine le coup de se
promener dans la ville et dans les
jardins et dans le domaine évidemment de
se promener avec ce guide forcément sous
le bras une parenthèse ou même juste sur
votre introduction puisque vous écrivez
que le site de Versailles réclame d'être
encore davantage protégé des menaces qui
le concernent quels sont les menaces qui
pèse on n'est jamais à l'abri des des
aménagements des des travaux c'est sûr
qu'il faut veiller
actuellement non mais on est on est on
voit quand on examine l'histoire du lieu
combien il a pu par miracle finalement
nous parvenir jusqu'à nous et il faut
rester vigilant parce qu'on ce n'est pas
à l'abri de nouvelles de nouvelles
menaces c'est un c'est on a une chance
formidable d'avoir conservé cette cet
ensemble et tout démembrement toute des
qualifications serait catastrophique on
en vient au cœur de l'ouvrage neuf
parcours du Trident quartier de
Montreuil des quartiers du vieux
Versailles Saint-Louis les jardins aussi
comment vous avez fait le choix de ces 9
balades historiques je voulais d'abord
insister sur les la ville qui est à des
quartiers distincts le quartier
Notre-Dame évidemment le quartier
Saint-Louis le vieux Versailles que l'on
connaît moins
examiné aussi c'était très important
pour moi le château en ville les
dépendances du château en ville le
château c'est pas seulement le bâtiment
principal c'est toute une nébuleuse de
ministère de de d'écuries de
l'hôtel des gendarmes tout ça toutes ces
dépendances qui qui n'existent que parce
que le château est là mais qui parsème
qui qui ponctue la ville donc il y a les
promenades dans la Ville invite aussi à
se rendre compte de cette dimension de
la de la présence du château dans la
ville
côté jardin j'ai proposé les itinéraires
en fait sur les pas de Louis XIV
lui-même qui avait rédigé donc une une
manière de montrer les jardins de
Versailles c'est un itinéraire Royal
formidable qui permet de parcourir
l'ensemble des jardins étant examiner
tous les points de vue et puis les
promenades à Trianon et dans le domaine
qui sont là un peu plus longues enfin
qui demande un peu plus de temps mais là
encore on peut les parcourir en les en
les fractionnant et et l'essentiel c'est
ce sont des promenades qui ont été
conçues pour pour le plaisir en tout cas
sur les bâtiments que vous avez
mentionné tout à l'heure la manière de
montrer les jardins de Versailles qui
avait été déjà conçu à l'époque par
Louis XIV mais pour le reste pour tous
les bâtiments c'est quel travail vous
avez mené vous êtes basé sur les
archives dont dispose le château
municipal Archives nationales et puis
les les articles il y a eu beaucoup
d'études portant sur tel ou tel aspect
des
bâtiments de la ville c'était quartiers
mais là c'était l'occasion d'en offrir
une synthèse on va voir quelques photos
justement alors c'est pas un
questionnaire piège mais vous pourrez
peut-être nous éclairer nous donner un
avant-goût de ce qu'on trouve dans le
livre c'est le Couvin la reine Lycéo qui
est un des plus belles ensemble un des
plus beaux ensembles de de
d'architecture monastique du 18e siècle
et qui est aussi été préservé de façon
miraculeuse jusqu'à nous et qui est la
restauration récente permet de
d'apprécier tout cet ensemble notamment
la chapelle dans toute sa beauté chaque
bâtiment à son histoire notre photo
peut-être le théâtre
dans les années
1990 et qui est un lieu tout à fait
intéressant de l'histoire du théâtre il
y a pas seulement l'Opéra royal il y a
aussi ce théâtre une dernière photo
allez vous êtes enterré
histoire nationale c'est là qui a été
prêté le serment du Jeu de Paume qui
marque le début de de l'assemblée de la
représentation nationale et donc ce lieu
là aussi est ouvert au public bien sûr
des lieux qui sont emblématiques qui
sont connus déjà mais ce qu'il y a des
richesses qui sont moins connues des
richesses méconnues à Versailles que
vous avez réussi à mettre en avant dans
l'ouvrage c'est tout ce qui concerne
alors pour rester dans la ville il y a
les glacières par exemple qui sont en
haut de la rue du Maréchal Joffre qui
sont pas beaucoup moins connus le
parcocer évidemment il y a beaucoup de
de légende de bruit qui courent sur
l'emplacement exact du parc aux cerf
alors on peut le découvrir au cours
d'une des promenades dans le quartier
Saint Louis il y a comme ça quantité de
aussi mon travail Montreuil est très mal
connu et une des promenades perpet
justement un excursus du côté de ce
quartier donc là on est côté ville et
puis il y a un côté jardin qu'on a
abordé tout à l'heure et là on peut
parler de véritable musée à ciel ouvert
c'est ce que vous puissiez ouvert tout à
fait et une mise en scène dans le parc
c'est vrai quelquefois et pourtant il y
a toute cette richesse alors évidemment
et
l'intérêt de suivre Louis XIV sur ses
pas sur le selon la manière de montrer
le jardin de Versailles c'est qu'il nous
invite à découvrir les les points de vue
les perspectives de découvrir que ce
domaine s'est grand tracé sont là pour
la satisfaction de l'oeil le plaisir de
l'esprit aussi de cette espèce de joie
de de voir que un territoire
parfaitement dominé par la main de
l'homme et à harmoniser agencer de
manière harmonieuse et les oeuvres d'art
les sculptures notamment sont là pour
souligner cette présence bienfaitrice de
la civilisation le guide est en français
est-ce que des éditions en langue
étrangère sont prévues pour les
touristes du monde entier on peut le
souhaiter oui bien sûr c'est mais c'est
vrai que pour commencer
samedi avec l'éditeur que le le public
francilien serait le premier évidemment
à s'intéresser à ce type de promenade
tout simplement parce qu'il est sur
place qu'il a le temps de les parcourir
mais si une de l'étranger et bien nous
nous orienterons vers une traduction en
anglais avec des mises à jour régulières
ce guide d'Alexandre Maral Versailles
côté ville côté jardin aux éditions de
passage merci d'être venu sur ce plateau
culture toujours allez on court à
présent la ferme du Mousseau a convié
deux artistes Olivier Michel Emmanuel
Rivière à partager espace et étant de
travail leurs univers leur création se
sont croisées le résultat est à
découvrir à travers une exposition
intitulée parasitage Guillaume national
pour ce sujet
parasitage c'est le nom de l'exposition
actuellement à la ferme du Mousseau le
temps d'une résidence d'artistes Olivier
Michel et Emmanuel Rivière ont réfléchi
ensemble sur la représentation visuelle
de parasites qui nous gêne pour la
contemplation du neuve explication alors
c'est un titre qui est un peu négatif on
a l'idée quand on parle de parasites des
idées de choses assez négatives et eux
ils avaient vraiment envie de réfléchir
sur cette histoire de qu'est-ce que
c'est qu'un parasite visuellement
comment notre vision d'un dessin d'une
forme elle peut être parasitée par une
autre forme les deux artistes
contemporains désiraient travailler
ensemble depuis longtemps grâce à cette
résidence à Elancourt ils ont pu enfin
réaliser leur souhaits et mettre leurs
talents en commun il y a eu quelque
chose d'extrêmement spontané dans cette
dans cette résidence vraiment quasiment
tous les jours je les voyais en train de
jouer littéralement à essayer des choses
il y a vraiment quelque chose de très
expérimental leur technique la
sérigraphie cela leur a permis de
répéter des motifs indéfiniment ils ont
ainsi créé des textures ressemblant à
des éléments organiques comme technique
de base sur le sur l'exposition de
techniques files rouges sur l'exposition
vous avez la sérigraphie c'est une
technique d'impression sur n'importe
quel support qui permet de reproduire à
l'infini autant de fois qu'on encre
l'écran de sérigraphie un même motif
tout le travail de création graphique
qui s'est articulé autour de des
possibilités techniques et artistiques
offerte par la sérigraphie en jouant sur
les coulures les absences de l'image les
saturations qu'est-ce qui se passe quand
on imprime plusieurs fois sans réancrer
on perd la définition de l'image du
qu'on arrive à des images fantômes qui
créent des blancs est-ce qu'on garde ses
blancs est-ce qu'on va les réencer voilà
tout un tas de possibilités graphiques à
partir de la sérigraphie
l'exposition se termine le 9 novembre
elle a déjà accueilli plus de 180
visiteurs
le Vietnam 54 ethnies différentes
chacune avec leurs costume et une
exposition est présentée en ce moment à
la mairie de Versailles au profit de
l'association Enfance partenariat
Vietnam Catherine zulator
des costumes plus colorés les uns que
les autres issus de 54 ethnies
différentes une initiative d'enfance
partenariat Vietnam pour se faire
connaître et faire partager cette
culture à l'origine de l'association il
y a 7 ans Florence cavalier son
association intervient en faveur des
enfants les plus en difficulté avec
notre histoire avec le Vietnam a
commencé il y a 21 ans lors de
l'adoption de nos deux filles aînées qui
ont maintenant donc 21 ans et du coup on
a été très reconnaissant envers le
Vietnam de nous permettre de devenir
parents à ce moment-là et on a souhaité
aider les enfants qui étaient dans les
orphelinats qui n'avaient pas la chance
d'être adopté tous les enfants
handicapés aussi qui nous touchaient
beaucoup depuis toutes ces années
Florence cavalier est allé une
quarantaine de fois au Vietnam elle
s'est attachée aux minorités
cettehniques et initie des de solidarité
récemment une savonnerie des projets de
formation professionnelle pour des
jeunes par exemple des ateliers de
couture des ateliers de réparation de
moto et de vélo et du coup ces ateliers
qui sont au sein de maisons sociales
permettent à des jeunes d'acquérir une
formation et au bout de deux à trois ans
ces ateliers sont autosuffisants et
arrivent à se s'auto gérer voilà mais
pour nous ce qui est très important
c'est vraiment qu'il y a une pérennité
du projet qui est un suivi et un
contrôle de notre projet l'an dernier
l'association a collecté 100000 euros
elle vient de terminer la construction
d'une école maternelle à la mairie de
Versailles outre l'exposition sont
également proposées des ateliers
d'origami de cuisine et des séances de
contes
il voulait bien en connaître sa supré
le compte ou plutôt des kamishibai ce
qui signifie théâtre d'image en japonais
à partir d'une structure en bois on
passe des images là ce sont des
peintures réalisées par des bénévoles le
secret il est simple et en même temps un
peu édulcoré c'est à dire qu'il faut
qu'il y ait une synthèse entre le texte
et l'image c'est à dire l'intérêt du
kamishibai c'est que l'image reste
plus longtemps que le texte que le que
les paroles donc l'enfant a le temps de
bien mettre les mots sur l'image les
animations se tiennent jusqu'au 14
novembre en mairie de Versailles
fin de ce journal à demain dès 18h pour
le direct reportage précédentes éditions
sont à revoir dès à présent sur notre
site Internet grâce au replay excellente
soirée